on se rend compte que beaucoup
d'entreprises encore aujourd'hui secret
avec peu de moyens une moyens financiers
se lance avec les moyens du bord
elle conseille c'est de se renseigner
vraiment au maximum de faire vraiment le
tour de tous les dispositifs qui
existent de vraiment travailler sur son
business plan sur le plan financement
sur les moyens opérationnels nécessaires
dès le départ pour démarrer son activité
faut pas se dire seulement voilà je m au
fur et à mesure nous faut vraiment dès
le départ de dire quels sont les moyens
qu'il faut mettre en place pour vraiment
créer mon activité dans les meilleures
conditions
aujourd'hui une entreprise n'est pas
parce qu'on ne peut pas fonctionner s'il
n'a pas de fonds propres il faut pas
minimiser ces investissements sont pas
émises et non plus ses fonds propres et
pour ça on est là pour ça non justement
possible de renforcer les fonds propres
de l'entreprise par le prêt d'un prêt à
taux zéro qui ai fait la personne de
manière à renforcer ses fonds propres et
pouvoir lever derrière après bancaire si
nécessaire devait un peu bancal plus
importants pour financer son projet on
donne vraiment une solution à une
problématique réunionnaise premier cycle
locale s'est beaucoup entreprises se
lancent avec très peu de fonds propres
et c'est le nerf de la guerre j'ai envie
de leur dire qu'il faut pas qu'il faut
pas avoir peur des de faire le tour au
pas avoir peur de rebondir c'est pas
parce qu'il ya un qui dit non que
l'autre va dire non derrière je parle
notamment des banques vraiment faire le
tour des banques pas s'arrêter une à
plusieurs sur la place et de toujours
rebondir tout sépare un à sept jours